12h15 sur la première c'est la fin de ce
journal tout de suite après celle andy
politique avec elle le dantec
il recevra farid mongolia le référent de
la république on marche à la réunion et
puis je vous rappelle que vous pouvez
suivre en direct sur lignon première
latte et lisent mon lit en hommage à
jacques chirac lundi politique
gaël le dantec
comme tous les responsables politiques
est notre invité et rend hommage à
jacques chirac émile moreau ce qu'il
retient de ce président de l'ancien
monde qu'à 30 illégalement de la visite
des manuels macron prévu elle dans les
semaines qui viennent nous le montrons
également commencé ici prendre défendre
ici à la réunion la politique du
gouvernement
quelles stratégies sont partis avec lui
qu'on marche quand elle mettre en oeuvre
pour les municipales quelle politique le
parti présidentiel
voudrait-il pardon pour la réunion farid
monrovia marche à la vie politique sur
la première jusqu'à 13h vos questions à
partir de 12h45 au 02 62 90 bonjour
bonjour merci beaucoup de m'avoir invité
vitry merci à vous d'avoir accepté notre
invitation d'autant plus que en cette
période de deuil national décrété pour
aujourd'hui
jacques chirac e.on en général dans une
trêve politique et politicienne et vous
avez bien voulu maintenir cette émission
politique sans merci dans l'attenté de
ce décès l'alsh irak les orages qui sont
rendus depuis jeudi
quelqu'un aujourd'hui et ce jour de
deuil de sa caisse quand quelqu'un est
ce que jacques chirac représente pour
vous qui était là ou pas d'argent alors
je rejouerai précise que je l'accepté
sans rendez vous il ya quelques semaines
déjà donc c'est un supplément que j ai
maintenu cet entretien policiers car
voilà donc la qualité fait que nous
avons aujourd'hui un hommage officiel
notre ancien président au moins ce qu'il
représente c'est le président de mon
enfance j'ai été enfin mon premier
engagement politique d'appeler dans les
urnes
il a été au lycée avec jacques chirac en
2002 au premier tour premier vers les
anciennes et est en position le pen qui
avait devancé le ps deux nageuses pas à
prendre afin que je me suis rendu compte
que ce qu'on vit dénouer des araignées
tais de tolérance et de vivre ensemble
n'est pas forcément quelque chose qui
était
naturellement établis hors de france
hier rennaise et qu' il y avait en
métropole maintenant on revienne un peu
en europe avec le populisme des
personnalités politiques qui ne
souhaitait pas qu'ils ne voulaient pas
voir dans sanaa france d'autres d'autres
personnes qui ne seraient pas comme ils
disent issue
des français de souche donc aujourd'hui
on ne voit que la problématique était
posée en 2002 est aujourd'hui devenu
presque une réalité avec la montée du
populisme
je me dis que jacques chirac était le
premier le premier grand défenseur de
la france les français et l'europe aussi
et que son deuxième mandat selon m
du coup c'était là au départ était
marqué n'était pas par ce fait marquant
qui que le fn est à nos portes
il fallait à tout prix se ressaisir et
s'unir pour vaincre 7,07 montée du
populisme qui qui depuis le 15 16 ans
comment faire du tord à la réunion on
voit tous les chapitres est même si
aujourd'hui avec le recul et tout ce
qu'on dit depuis c'est là qu'il faut
entendre qu'il était très pragmatique on
politique et pas forcément un idéologue
il était peut-être lui aussi à sa façon
comme le dit aujourd'hui et droite et de
gauche
malgré tout les mêmes manoeuvres
politiciennes et à créer des repères il
était il incarner la droite
comment est ce que vous voyez ça vous
aujourd'hui qu'ils pensent souvent que
vu dépasser ses frontières politiques
solides ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
comment ce camp politique
yara premier tour un second tour le
premier tour en général il ya souvent
une petite partie centrale du parti ou
du mouvement qui défend les valeurs
qu'ils défendent des valeurs et que le
président fera car ni les départs et dès
le moment où ce n'est plus le président
de la partie on n'est plus le président
d'un mouvement
on ne recensait président des français
donc c'est tout naturellement tout
président depuis je pense et j'espère de
vue général du golf a pu le faire ont
toujours souhaité avoir une large
majorité donc aux trois gauche à droite
attendu en limitant cette action extrême
aujourd'hui jacques chirac a été celui
qui dès 2002 et la communication c'est
pas facile
il a cohabité avec eux la juste part
entre le premier ministre m'ont bien que
malgré les difficultés rencontrées par
rapport à ce qu'on a tenu à pm en tant
que thème de droite
aujourd'hui je pense que il a été un des
précurseurs qui a su être service des
français et dépasser ce clivage une fois
qu'ils étaient lus
on voit quand on regarde aujourd'hui
comment est-ce qu'il était comme comme
politicien on voit l'importance de la
proximité de l'ancrage dans la réalité
le cas c'est ce que tout le monde salue
jeu chirac aujourd'hui est ce que est ce
que c'est ce qui manque un peu ce côté
très secret très terroir presque
j'aimerais dire là dessus c'est que le
présent dans le public il une fois la
réunion c'est pendant la campagne 2010
est et de mémoire je pense que jacques
chirac est venu une bonne douzaine le
fallait de réunion ce qui montre que
tout se fait dans le temps ne veut pas
en compte au final dans la chirac et qui
va aider aussi on n'y avait pas internet
et la société le plus profité du temps
donc s'il comptait à l'époque c'était la
proximité avec les élus qui étaient en
place à la réunion on a pu voir que
certains élus ont été sont en génération
à chaque qui ont en fait trois quatre
années et vous dira que c'est la
proximité avec ses élus et valérie
données qui ont fait que il revenu
plusieurs fois lui la réunion comme ça à
venir avant d'être président en tant que
ministre il est venu à la réunion
confidentielle et aujourd'hui je crois
que ce qui a fait son succès dans les
outre-mer c'est que il est
il est venu une fois il est venu en tant
qu'ancien et de revenus ces vacances il
revenu aussi pour henry président il est
notre mère il aimait l'idée de
l'outre-mer il aimait réunion donc
forcément dans sa missive amitié avec
des élus voir ce qu'ils ont fait aux
déclarations à la presse et quelques
joies et les amis ses fortes ont du coup
l'amitié en dehors de la politique aussi
cinq ans pour un territoire
est ce que vous dites voilà qu il fera
chaque époque il y à ce qui ce qui se
fait dans des lieux aujourd'hui comme
plaisir en 2007 à 2009 il ya eu
tellement d'avancé technologique est
tellement c'est aussi l'invention des
moeurs que ce qui se faisait avant
franchement plus pareil aujourd'hui
c'est que le président reste le
président de percevoir un président et
est différente aujourd'hui que qu'il
rentre avec
chirac en 2002 par exemple est-ce que
qu'est ce qu'est ce que ça vous enseigne
à vous phare immo façon ça fait de la
politique on a progressé politiques et
les autres concurrents qu'est ce que ça
vous enseigne à vous soit façon par la
politique parce que ce que je retiens de
son parcours politique commencé très
jeune si je me trompe pas il était
député à 33 34 ans donc ça montre bien
aujourd'hui que ceux qui veulent faire
croire qu'un président un bon président
en bon politicien ou un bon élu
recommencer absolument traita donc la
preuve vrai que jacques chirac est l'un
de nos plus grands présidents que public
il a commencé sa carrière très tôt il a
été élu dès sa sortie de l'ena et de
sciences po aujourd'hui être député à 34
ans vos vues pour sa trace après ça
alors que jacques chirac l'a fait il ya
de ça 60 ans donc je pense que le fait
de commencer très jeune il des tribunes
avoir des idées et de ce bar pour durer
pour durer a pour simuler et quand les
proches forcément c'est les lui il est à
craindre que les renards en vue mais pas
que il ya toujours été proche des
français d'outre-mer et en métropole
donc aujourd'hui je pense à la proximité
et comment ces jeunes ça vous inspire
vous personnellement
voilà ça c'est une carrière que je me
faire personnellement quand je vois
chirac le président est aujourd'hui
encore notre président la république
mais ce qui compte c'est que on pense
que c'est possible quand les camps les
jeunes aujourd'hui par des jeunes qui
sont aujourd'hui qui peuvent être déçus
ou qui peuvent être aussi pessimiste
qu'on voit le parcours du président de
la république on se dit que on peut
commencer jeune on peut aller très loin
s'ils ont perdu eux aussi on est
toujours en droit dans ses bottes et si
on avance avec un objectif qui est de
jouer des françaises et des français je
suis pas trop voulu défendre justement
la politique d'achat sur les retraites
parenthèse frères thesse que que
bienvenu marron or pour l'instant si
l'annoncé en octobre
donc on voit bien qu'on finisse un
avenir donc vaut aujourd'hui on est au
nirvana capacité de je pense de didier
qui va venir lit de la réunion en
octobre il annoncé lui même crédité sont
unies à new york donc les dates ne sont
pas encore arrêtées donc je pense que
dès que l'état seront arrêtés vous serez
en trois mois les premiers à être au
courant des dates et des élus parcours
sud est de la réunion donc je pense que
c'est une visite qui a tendu visite qui
est nécessaire parce qu'aujourd'hui je
pense que les réunionnaises n'ont besoin
d'eux
c'est approprié présent à public levrat
entre le président pour continuer de
discuter avec lui qui viennent à notre
rencontre il voir échanger se prononcer
du coup si ça fait quoi exactement
mais c'est sans fin jeudi au mandat
public
ils visitent tous les départements et
toutes les régions au maximum durant ce
quinquennat
aujourd'hui ça fait deux ans on va dire
qu'il est qu'il est lui donc je pense
que tout simplement comme comme tout
ministre qui valait de la réunion pour
voir les avancées vers le pronostic de 6
à cette même optique c'est à dire dans
un premier temps enfin de tout ce qui a
été fait pendant 2 ans voit aussi
qu'est-ce qui est en cours et qu'est ce
qui pourrait être fait pour améliorer
notre quotidien
donc essentielle s'inscrit comme une
place que 300 c'est quelque chose dans
ses valises qui sont directement au
président mais au jour d'aujourd'hui je
pense que le président a montré qu' il
est pragmatique il avance et depuis deux
ans il réforme fait des réformes
courageuses il est au contact de la
population malgré ce que ce qu'on peut
dire aujourd'hui je pense qu'elle a
besoin aussi le me voir directement et
de la réunion valérie nazaire est menée
et échanger avec nous je pense moi que
je vais pas dire à l'avancé quel sera
son programme mais je pense que le
besoin d'un président c'est être contre
la population de parler directement avec
la population et de voir quelles sont
ses attentes
c'est en six heures ça pas de sens parce
que sa cote de popularité est
particulièrement basse auprès des
réunions sans qu'un nouveau au baromètre
qui a été réalisé par s'agisse pour
gérer une première
quelques semaines maintenant 76%
mauvaises opinions comment est-ce qu'on
est ailleurs
je vais là je vais vous parler en tant
que réunionnais je suis moi-même
rayonner je suis gionis ya donc moi je
pense que le mauvais score que qu'a eus
le président sur ce sondage il est d'une
méconnaissance des bonnes choses qui
sont faites produits de la région
il semble communication pour cent mais
une bonne partie des personnes savoir
que dans tout dans toutes nos troupes
tout en art quinquennat il ya
l'opposition l'opposition ne sera jamais
de votre côté me suis fait des bonnes
choses
ils vont te poser le parolier des
mesures pour que le réseau toujours à
vue qu'à vous quel rôle est ici pour ça
comptera général depuis 2007 nous avons
eu très peu de temps
vos jours nous avons deux super élus qui
font le travail c'est à dire stéphane
bijoux livres européens et j'allais
manquer ce qui est sénateur donc
aujourd'hui grâce à ses 2 ces deux rues
les rames pouvant agir commencer à
travailler un peu mieux et sereinement
sur le territoire d'ici pas suffisant au
jour d'aujourd'hui tout le travail qui a
été fait avec
monsieur donald macron surpris n'y ont
pas beaucoup de cendres en parles tu
restes en attendait toujours à 42% de de
rayonner en dessous du seuil de pauvreté
qu'est ce que vous leur vie qu'ils
peuvent encore attendre des promesses je
pense qu'aujourd'hui le café aussi par
le biais de la mini c'est trop bien
qu'irrégulièrement nous y allait de la
réunion je pense qu'il ya eu des moments
forts et que malheureusement qui n'ont
pas été traités très bien volleyé
aujourd'hui prendre un seul exemple qui
va parler à adémistes rennes minutes
personne
le rsa pendant des années le rsa c'était
le département le conseil général qui
était en charge justement de la réunion
vaut aujourd'hui avec la route avec le
sac et centralisée directement qui
quittera et je vous a fait de la marge
supplémentaire pour le département le
département aujourd'hui mais c'est la
nature l'a dit je prends sur ce que vous
en dis à très longtemps
le rsa qui est centralisé ç'a permis au
département n'aura plus de marge de
manoeuvre et ivoire millions d'euros
dont il ne doit en plus pour les
réunionnaises et des réunionnais si
c'est concret qui sait tout de suite la
mistral jardin lors de son dernier
quelques jours avant ses mille places
supplémentaires les parcours ont la
compétence
on se souvient que les employés c'était
une solution que ça s'est référé au
clientélisme des élus locaux et puis
finalement bas il en remet pas ce que
parce que nous ressentons que que
c'était utilisent ce qui se passe avec
eux les contrats on va dire aidé c'est
que ouvre aujourd'hui nous savons tous
que le pronostic emploi ils n'ont pas
aussi par l'information
donc aujourd'hui je pense que le
parcours en emploi compétences le pecs
et
je suis pas qu'il est nécessaire pour
lui de la réunion et qu'il est encore
moins qu'il est parti qu'il est nos
délices me dégoûte éviter mais il est
indéniable aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui s'il ya des emplois qui sont
correctement distribués et avec les
formations en parallèle ça permet de dd
de sortir les personnes qui sont hors du
circuit à eau du monde du travail
ça permet de les aider mais c'est vrai
que si elle si elle arrive le succès de
ne cédera pas à grand chose si ce n'est
rendre plus précaires c'est qu'ils sont
chrétiens et ceux qui n'ont plus ces
contrats aidés qui leur permettait de
vivre de faire vivre la famille
aujourd'hui on est en été a dit mais
qu'est ce que qu'est ce que vous leur
dis pas cela parce que qu'est son poids
qui était censé remplacer sont alors
déjà c'est pas c'est pas dit niels et 11
me et plus et plus 1000 donc douze mille
du coup au final pour e.on et moi mais
de la moitié moins que le verre à moitié
vide mais il fait que années on disait
que le crâne est né sais plus donc c'est
une profession déjà comme une question
des flux de copains dit que c'était
supprimés aujourd'hui on dit que ça
diminue et donc c'est déjà bon c'est un
bon point
douze mille 2000 paix qu il faut savoir
aussi que abandonné
aujourd'hui il ya eu en effet 500 déjà
consommé à l'île de la réunion il ya une
mission supplémentaire qui vont qui vont
débloquer plus 1000 que la miss a promis
lors de son voyage
ça fait 2500 donc vous donner 500
contrats qui vont qui vont être odieux
fin d'année et surtout il ya aussi la
lutte contre la dengue
je pense que ces contrats là vont servir
pour une bonne partie à lutter contre la
dengue donc c'est pour des
les causes nobles santé publique donc
jour je pense que il ya des cas où c'est
nécessaire
après c'est vrai que si les utiliser et
qu'on ne va pas en quoi
en quoi la possibilité se sont
améliorées avec ces contrats-là savait
qu'on pose des questions mais là il y
aura des contrats pub pour je veux
lutter contre la dengue à l'est de la
réunion le quinquennat son acte 2
deuxième partie finalement du programme
politique des meilleurs ça veut dire
quoi concrètement
il avait la queue aujourd'hui avec leurs
efforts les plus démunis cette
présidence
aujourd'hui hélas trois ans de la chose
quinquennat aujourd'hui ça veut dire que
deux ça veut dire que pendant ces deux
années là on a eu des combats on a eu
les législatives
on a eu aussi la crise dj les jeunes
aujourd'hui ça veut dire que l'enfant
on va dire grandi c'est que avec la
convention à le faut je veux qu'on ne
savait pas qui a eu lieu en ces temps là
pu voir que c'est une sorte d'université
on va dire même sollicité parce que la
parole était donnée justement aux
marcheurs pour dans différents ateliers
et avec eux plus de 4000 personnes qui
étaient qui était sur place à bordeaux
j'ai été aussi l'occasion de montrer que
le chemin des facile et 2 c'est un
virage à gauche ou même virage à droite
c'est au jour d'aujourd'hui on montre
avec
la politique du gouvernement on n'est ni
à droite ni à gauche donc et ça je pense
que tout le monde peut le voir
aujourd'hui a dit la ministre au maire
qui sociale je suis à l'écouté comme je
suis sympa que département on voit
qu'avec l'aide
quant au département social innovant
avec aussi et ça c'est d'actualité avec
les nounous d'euros qui ont été
annoncées par la ministre il ya sept
jours pour lutter contre les mafias et
nous quittant cet argent qui était prévu
pour le logement et qui seront pas
utilisées pour la course sur le fond
c'est vraiment plus ça sort pas comme ça
de vie mais c'est à dire que quand que
que quand on regarde les buts g pour
justement améliorer les opérations
on nous sort que lui que c'était parce
qu'il est plus court chose aujourd'hui
je prouve que yahia a besoin social à la
réunion et je pense que le département
était écoutée au niveau social et que
montano damak le département pour faire
avancer le savoir et non de provoquer
des rousses a commencé qu est ce que
vous dites à ce rêve n'est qu'ils vont
devoir travailler plus longtemps
moi ce que je veux dire il est très
large a su sais que personnellement je
suis d'une génération nous sommes 2e
génération incertaine donc aujourd'hui
on se demande comment nous
dans quarante cinquante ans on saura on
se dira ce niveau là je pense qu'à m'en
donner sens au détail ou si on ne défend
pas avant ce sera le compliqué attendez
tout le monde sera tout sera lésé yeoh
en critiquant une équité pouvoir il n'a
pas fait d'effort et on reviendra en
arrière mais travailler ensemble tout de
suite pour trouver la meilleure solution
je pense que le les forces nécessaires a
donc à beaucoup de niveaux
donc il faut savoir prendre la mesure
des démos et pas juste critiquer pour
pour l'électorat et pour les élections
qui arrivent très bientôt du sens dans
le débat national qu'il a été reportée
pour cause de deuil national
un débat sans vote sur l'immigration est
ce que c'est nécessaire que c'est une
façon de couper l'herbe sous le pied
durant son mandat ce qui l'a vu contre
anne de vraies propositions à faire ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'aujourd'hui pas
d'immigration parle tout de suite de
marée humaine parce que c'est son fond
de commerce de prendre des migrations
pour sensibiliser pour choquer même
lectra et pour que les et pour
stigmatiser une partie des populations
aujourd'hui ce qu'on dit aujourd'hui
comme on disait à six mois pour les
européennes on disait que le l'écologie
n'est pas propre parti écolo tout comme
l'immigration n'est pas propre au parti
considère donc aujourd'hui ça si des
phénomènes qui touche tout le monde et
tu les parties dans toute l'europe donc
vôtre aujourd'hui je pense pas qu'il
faut qu'il y ait par exemple revoir
l'aide médicale aux étrangers vous est
favorable
ce qu'il faut voir c'est que abandonné
appelé niveau il ya eu des réformes de
l'éducation au niveau de prise en charge
de
jose est ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'à
un moment donné si on peut pas subvenir
aux besoins de forcément réformes et des
solutions pour pouvoir pour que tout le
monde puisse être être bien aussi donc
quand les fonds pour enlever ou pour
pour finir c'est pour justement mieux
adapter les dispositifs qui existent et
que le mieux possible la pma pourquoi
profession mais qu'avant c'était pour
toutes les femmes at il promis
ces assemblées il a été adopté à
l'assemblée qu'elle est votre blessure
vous sur cette question là il faut les
plages et sachant produit par une partie
de ceux qui ont donc que ce que je dis
souvent c'est que quand il ya des grèves
au son de loi qui a des projets de loi
l'opposition dit toujours qu'il faut il
faut aller plus loin c'est insuffisant
aussi noms qui sont carrément contre
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il ya eu un
grand pas qui a été fait avec la pma
donc c'est ainsi que donc forcément je
pense que à chaque et comme je disais
justement pour eux l'attention du
président républicain chaque élection et
à chacun et à chaque période
il ya son lot de changements il faut
voir les choses que vous faites
je suis la majorité présidentielle donc
lier les projets de loi et aux plus gros
tournoi éventuellement et naturellement
nous sommes tous derrière sinon ce sont
les premiers à des compagnies font pas
dire si la prophétie avec
agir avec le modem avec eux ainsi le
mouvement radical salle et avec eux les
gist mais vous savez ça descend bien que
nous sommes nous sommes un parti très
ouvert je suis vraiment pas réfuter si
j'étais député j'ai joué je n'ai pu
m'exprimer là dessus aujourd'hui en tant
que référent départemental pour a vu
comment ce que je peux vous dire
aujourd'hui c'est que nous sommes à
notre président sommes derrière son
projet et son programme et nous sommes
tous derrière lui et la divergence dans
le groupe dans le clan parité et pas
grand et pas dans la bon dire la révolte
est dans l'opposition nous sommes pas
contre un complément chaque fois ce qui
dit qu'il est nécessaire et nous sommes
pas là pour critiquer ran comme comme
certains députés réunionnais ou hors de
métropole qui dès qu'ils ont eu peur que
l'opinion favorable à une mesure
critique pour justement cristalliser les
événements est-ce que leur vouent verra
pendant les élections municipales
mars 2020 sur une liste en tête de lice
n'ont pas du tout quiz je disais après
s'il ya six mois quand j'étais une
référence partie mentale que tout en six
politiques vocation d'aller aux
élections présidentielles
personnellement vous comme que nous y
serons forcément les aujourd'hui j'ai
une position qui est des centrales dit
stratégiques au sein de la même réunion
donc je suis le référent nous je suis en
charge de
de déterminer la stratégie e ri duel est
de dénicher de nouveaux talents sur la
réunion pour les élections nationales
mans je ferai partie de cette équipe là
il faut savoir organiser organisé à plus
haut niveau de la réunion c'était sur la
est-ce que vous êtes candidat vous
personnellement je sais sur liste c'est
sur cette position aujourd'hui je serai
tête de liste je serai sur une liste
pour apporter
comment dire pas porter mon engagement
est une condition sur ce champ de
communes ce rallye ça ce ça se discute
pour aujourd'hui aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
rien n'a été décidé renate fils et nous
sommes en commission départementale
d'investiture depuis quelques mois et
nous sommes bien avancés sur plus de
communes est pour l'instant n'ont pas
arrêté de liste et les têtes de liste
pour plutôt comme une approche quand
même ça s'approche lui et non parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes nous sommes
en position j'ai apprécié de force à
l'île de la réunion
nous sommes en jeu notamment pas élu
donc nous sommes très contents que de
nous projeter et de voir quelle est la
meilleure stratégie sur sur les communes
donc vraiment plusieurs communes et de
la réunion nous ne sommes pas nous
sommes pas pressés par amour est restée
aminés qui après être doublé vous n'êtes
pas céder vous allez dans sa commune
avoir des listes dans certaines autres
patience la stratégie générale a annoncé
que nous avons un comité départemental
d'aidé si sûr donc nous statuant sur les
demandes des investisseurs ce qu'ils
veulent
investi pour une tête de liste le chef
de file sur une notion commune pouvait
candidat je cache pas nous avons eu
beaucoup de candidatures à l'investiture
nous avons subi beaucoup de ménages est
aussi un soutien comme tout est encore
au stade de l'étude et
non annoncée de nancy 2-2 les projets
pour les communes en démontrant que nous
sommes fous annoncé les candidats vont
s'achever sur une journée au niveau
national les alliances de la marche se
font pour l'instant avec départ qu'il
devra essentiellement ce que ça sera le
cas ici avec michel dennemont serviront
qu'à rassembler toute la droite qui le
soutient est ce que ça sera tant
d'autres produits ne pas parler de
politique politicienne par les
municipales dans cet entretien mais j'ai
quand même eu clarifier plusieurs chats
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui nous n'avons
pas de parti pris d'être allé avec la
droite ou la gauche
donc il ya des communes en métropole ou
le ps la gauche soit sera partout il ya
des communes ou et à la droite seront
les partenaires donc c'est vraiment il
faut distinguer en fait les les villes
et les appartements ils sont tous
différents donc pas comparer les parents
d'outre-mer afin que attaquant soit avec
paris donc c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
au cas par cas si c'est pour ça que
j'aime qualité des présentations
je ne suis le département pour avoir la
meilleure qu'ils ont aussi sur les
candidats investir ou non quels sont vos
rapports aujourd'hui l'élu de deux
pièces qu'il va laisser son siège de
sénateur c'était prévu et du coup vous
perdez un siège et une voix celle à ces
questions il faut les poser directement
personnes concernées je ne suis que vous
aussi vous avez un sénateur certainement
que nous avons député européen
stéphanie joue beaucoup avec ces deux
parlementaires qui sont complémentaires
et un bruxelles
aujourd'hui moi je ne vote pas cette
question là si michel dennemont va voir
si vous restez et sion la question est
qui se pose est celle de la pesée moi
aujourd'hui sur référent départemental
je ne suis pas sa place à saint denis
mais évidemment ça va être important des
municipales endroits importants en
imaginant que didier robert se présente
comment est-ce que la république en
marche va se positionner entre un didier
robert qui qui se déclare très macro
compatible entrevues et un gilbert
annette qui était un de ceux qui a
invité ma croix bien sa campagne ici
comment est ce que vous avez contre les
listes soutenir l'un l'autre les deux il
n'y a pas de
il n'y a pas de d'idée arrêtée pour
l'instant sur la question nous sommes à
sa progression donc aussi si si je pense
que je compense le temps de discuter
fait une conférence de presse et du
granon ses candidats pour les communes
aujourd'hui la parité je discute avec
tout le monde
donc je n'ai pas peur de dire que je
suis référente parental donc je
rencontre tout le monde plus zélés de
l'île de la réunion de droite de gauche
et nous sommes nous sommes en pleine
structuration si au niveau du bureau
départemental donc jours julien est
arrêté et je dirais même qu'il ya très
peu de candidats faire très peu de
maires qui sont déjà candidats
aujourd'hui donc tout le monde
tout le monde travaille comme on
essayait de trouver les meilleures
stratégies pour avancer il pour faire
gagner leur mouvement la partie et leurs
concitoyens personnellement en tant que
jeune izia je serai forcément intéressé
de travailler sur cette nuit en
particulier mais entre le fonds
départemental
je reviens sur l'île de la réunion et je
suis là pour chapeauter les 24 communes
et trouver les meilleurs scientifiques
ou vingt quatre communes en demi finales
départementales quelle est l'ambition
qu'il faut bien assez vite derrière
parce que votre idée c'est de construire
maëlys d'aller et si l'on passé des
alliances exfolier non si je vous si je
vous dis qu'il faut ici pas nous sommes
pas encore arrêté ça veut dire que pour
les vêtements mais dans les grandes
lignes et inventer chaque jour suffit sa
peine
et aujourd'hui la stratégie globale dans
le maximum d'élus donc vous soyez de la
réunion en métropole 2 août revient donc
nous nous réfléchissons à voir aussi un
maximum de conséquences et des missiles
pour vous
c'est qu'aujourd'hui ici il y a des
communes où le pouvons être listes vont
à glisser sur certains donc je vois que
quand j'entends le parti écologiste à
l'est de la réunion pour un jean pierre
marchau qui dit qu'avec son score aux
européennes il va reconsidérer les
supporter continuation plusieurs
communes donc qu'on va le square nous
c'est le double de élevées donc nous si
vraiment on a reprécisé de monter des
listes en plus sa commune
aujourd'hui nous ne sommes pas encore
arrêté donc les municipales arrive dans
six mois maintenant donc tous nous avons
beaucoup de personnalité qui nous ont
rejoints depuis quelques années nous
avons beaucoup de comités qui sont
portées par des sociétés civiles et
c'est vous le rappeler aujourd'hui
d'avoir le 2 ça je pense que c'est ces
choses que l'on qu'on allait passer du
militaire à l'est de la réunion le 10
pour ceux qui sont intéressés pour
t'aider liste forcément vocation à tous
les jours aujourd'hui ce qui compte
c'est que la communication qui fait
actuellement sur les complices tracé
moss et morale à moi et à monsieur
stéphane dijoux et missionnement donc
les adhérents comment si vous dites que
vous ne voyez pas je pose la question se
trouvaient les adhérents de l air à la
réunion 5% aux européennes
jusqu'où va les adhérents de sa réunion
5 france open on ne va pas non plus donc
je comprends que peut-être que la figure
non plus revoir à 2-2 d'élus qui voilà
qui revendiquent leur appartenance et
qui viennent au micro défendre et un peu
invisible invisible vif quand vous dites
c'est que l'invisible en même temps si
on compare à celle de la réunion lé ps
et quelques ailes
il est aujourd'hui sort dandy dlr il
veut porter une liste à l'air à l'est de
la région
donc si je suis preneur je n'ai pas de
jeu n'est pas attendu quelques semaines
des candidats souvent ce qui des années
après que d'aménagements et de
politiques globales de la réunion même
si vous le dites il est trop tôt pour
parler des changes il ya des choses vont
se jouer là et puis savoir ce que vous
avez envie de faire de la réunion si
vous êtes d'une façon d'une autre
branche du pouvoir local en terme
d'aménagement notamment commerciales
surface il faut réfléchir autrement est
ce que c'est vous en tant que vous êtes
sûr bien entendu la saison s'affrontent
bien comme comme politique ce qui s' il
faut savoir c'est que depuis des années
il ya toujours eu des personnalités
politiques ou du monde économique qui
ont tous jeté pour un moratoire sur la
réunion pour la façon des grandes
surfaces vous que j'ai pour l'instant
question de terre qu'on puisse voir
justement bas parce qu'il faut avoir
fait que les cdac des conditions dans
lesquelles on libère peuvent valider un
projet et le projet est en suspens et le
projet et 150 donc ses valises c'est
validé donc ce qui compte aujourd'hui
qu'un moratoire un peu gelé pendant
cette période le temps qu'on puisse
trouver la solution
après paul et de la réunion et je pense
que c'est une bonne mesure parce que je
pense que à la fois trop bien à qui et à
quoi je dis qu'il faut un moratoire pour
ses plantations je pense que c'est un
message fort qui est envoyé au président
azéri nul et c'est que ce qui compte
c'est pas savoir ce qu'il faut deux ou
trois quatre ans que nation c est ce que
en ayant plus d'offres les prix baissent
les prix baissent est-ce que
aujourd'hui on pouvait rentrer que les
prix baissent et que les rennaises
rayonner puissent avoir leur avantage
dans cette transaction
c'est le but c'est que les données
soient avantagés avec la miss d'offres
mais si nous avons un maximum d'offres
et des sentiers qui sauvent et que les
prix y reste le même
avant de tout le monde dit son
opposition à cette aile et vous votre
lecture de ce dossier
les curés simple c'est que aujourd'hui
il ya bel et bien vous valez makita
membres donc assez de ce moment là il y
aura des offres eux qui sont faites par
les heureux acquéreurs et après il y
aura une autorité indépendante non le
fait que je souhaite est ce que ça vous
êtes vous de la politique et à eux en
tant que telle était indépendante a
statué sur vous habitez ou non par
rapport à là où est la ministre a noté
la ministre a dit que même après la vie
la commission peut être que louvain on
pourrait recevoir les avis des élus sont
bien les jeunes glowacki je sais que là
n'est ce pas demander un moratoire pour
eux les habitations ils apprennent eux
ne pas ouvrir des négociations et une
table ronde pour discuter avec les
partis flamands pour voir qu'est ce que
des solutions donc aujourd'hui vient
effet aujourd'hui il ya partout ce qui
est sûr c'est que mardi mais avant ça
c'est sûr et pour tous il est rappelé à
s'en verra en eux qu'est-ce qui est ce
qui sera fait et il faut savoir et avec
qui parce qu'il ya eu et a lieu depuis
de nombreuses années d importation
connaissant de la réunion c'est vrai
mais c'est quand même un laminé c'est le
premier qui qui qui est à la crise qui a
dit là où quelques années beaucoup en
cdac donc c'est vrai je pense que c'est
plus un travail à faire en interne où
nous élus annulé de la réunion savoir
qu'est ce que vous faites de la réunion
la réunion
qu'est-ce qu'on fait des aménagements
mais ça ne vous dit rien vous voulez pas
vous qu'il faut pas que robin est trash
et d'ailleurs vous aujourd'hui ce que je
dis c'est que c'est à nous réunionnais
le décider qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
notre part notre île donc si il a
l'impression qu'ils ont été décidées par
des mères
quand je parle de rachat des biens par
d'autres élus le bafana des biens si si
un rachat
c'est que il ya yann acheteurs et qu' il
ya le walkie en vente
côté ratios qui va acheter moi
personnellement aujourd'hui je ne suis
pas là c'est pour vous dire qu'il a été
acheté sli sur ces deux vallées net
avant et que les opérations commerciales
à l'est d'avignon ont été validées par
les élus à la réunion est pas parvenu
vraiment les alertes sur le
réchauffement s'ils sont bien d'autres
essences toute façon simple et y sont
devenus écolos mais dans la réalité on
est loin des 10 et le prêt je joue plus
de voitures sur les routes ou dans plus
de pollution toujours plus tintin est ce
que finalement pour venir cette affaire
deux d'importation faire parce que c'est
peut-être lié ce que notre modèle de
développement basé sur la croissance est
à revoir à réviser ce qui est sûr c'est
que appelé niveau le commerce de
proximité est aussi une réponse aussi
haut que lui parce que prendre sa
voiture pour aller consommer plus loin
si c'est de cette vue pouvoir d'achat en
moins et c'est aussi c'est vraiment le
ne pas faire un effort pour le jeune
oncle pessimiste et je trouve que c'est
une des mesures qui étaient prises en
or la finance il ya eu des mesures qui
ont jeté en place pour favoriser le
commerce de proximité
sanou élu et reconnu la réunion du
favorisés c'est comment dire il est
favorisé la mise en place de ces mesures
un pour que puissent consommer local
puissent consommer près chez eux et on a
su se dépasser pour consommer la même
chose plus loin ça vient il faut il faut
aller plus loin dans la réglementation
dans le look associés
j'espérais que l'offre exemple en u17 la
finance il ya eu il ya eu une aide pour
les tpe et les commerçants de proximité
qui avait un local commercial de 1 400
mètres à l'est sur un sentier pas
commercial c'est-à-dire hors centres
commerciaux à avoir une baisse de taxe
foncière sur le bâti
donc on va dire que c'est quoi tout cela
si c'est une taxe qui est payé par le
locataire propriétaire qui quittent les
commerçants aujourd'hui il ya zéro
depuis deux ans pour favoriser la baisse
des loyers vous et aussi du pouvoir
d'achat d'actions des commerçants il n'a
eu qu'à ce jour la réunion un seul maire
qui a mis en place cette mesure et ce
courant et je trouve ça assez assez il y
avait trois communes qui mérite d'être
vous faire appliquer notamment ceni je
pense que ces travaux de proximité
ça pouvait donner donner des idées à
d'autres grands groupes d'amis
centre-ville aussi est ce que pour
revenir en question plus générale de des
voltigeurs est que le libération qui
impute à la politique menée par
commencer ce qu'il doit aujourd'hui être
un peu plus un t2 de protectionnisme de
taxation par les télévisions
ce qu'il faut plus d'intervention de
l'état et gestes simples aujourd'hui on
veut pas dire qu'on est mené avec la
population c'est l'écologie
une parade des mesures en place pour
pour que nous ne puissions vivre besoin
dans une île est un pays avec
un vrai changement de mentalité mais en
réalité des réunionnais au jour
d'aujourd'hui des françaises et des
français je pense qu'il faut qu'on s'en
soit fait déjà au niveau local et au
niveau de tout un chacun
moi personnellement je passe ma fille
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il faut un peu
de tout on ne peut pas que penser à
tracer les entreprises et demandé que la
france a fait par tout le monde donc je
pense qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde doit
pouvoir à son niveau
travailler sur ses habitudes de
consommation au dessus de dépassement
est aussi avoir une conscience
écologique
c'est la prise de conscience et par la
réglementation votre idée il faut les
deux mais je pense que le ski est
confiée tout de suite de conscience
réserver dès maintenant et je pense que
ça serait plus parle pas beaucoup dix
ans vous avez évoqué entre début
d'émission le rapport à que le
rassemblement du front national qui
était 5e ce qui laisserait noir de
marier une convention dans laquelle eric
zemmour les propos anti immigrés et anti
islam qui est rangé le tout diffusé en
direct sur une chaîne de télévision
ça vous inquiète cette banalisation à
ski sur aujourd'hui c'est que nous avons
la montée des extrêmes et qui sont de
plus en plus extrêmes donc on fera
qu'avec mon chien le pen elle et elle
est je pense un peu plus plus à droite
que sa tante
donc je pense qu'avec ce qui s'est passé
cette semaine avec la console à droite
avec eric zemmour qui lancent des propos
aussi aussi dangereux que l'inconscient
je pense qu'il ya une banalisation à
l'est déjà depuis très longtemps mais je
pense que vaut aujourd'hui le politique
le il a un public qui écoute et qui les
pousse et idées ça qui m'inquiète que
qu'il est raciste et qui sont contre le
sun qui sont entre guillemets français
de souche
c'est un peu ce un peu
ça peut choquer mais ça existe
malheureusement aujourd'hui sont de plus
en plus nombreux épouser les idées de
l'hexagone aujourd'hui d'avoir un
discours cohérent de vivre ensemble et
de la réunion pour montrer que ce qui se
passe selon m forcément c'est pas
forcément le cas il a raison il faut
travailler là dessus pour montrer un
exemple pour une fois complémentaires
exemple ailleurs je pense qu'il faut
être partout ne sont pas initial merci à
vous faire participer à ce lundi
politiques passaient leur journée sur la
première
[Musique]